starting next month the new experience  is opening on mount charleston bringing  new life to the site of the iconic lodge  that building was destroyed in the fire  in september of last year now a  temporary structure is going up for  what's being called pine dining a summer  chef cookout series starts july 23rd and  will feature different local chefs each  bringing a new menu to the mountain  something worth noting there's no  parking available on the mountain so  once you buy tickets you'll get  information on the available shuttle  service you can also book a cabin just  make a weekend out of it but local chefs  there  pine dining